comment tu t'intitules qui viennent ça
va mon chéri ton petit donner un micro
mais il va parler comme ça dans sa barbe
tu vas attendre les micros à chaque fois
alors quel âge as-tu j'ai 17 ans 17 ans
tu repars
au lycée au lycée quelqu'un
je suis en terminale frère tu es chelou
[Applaudissements]
frère tu es très chelou je suis en
Première terminale
bah tu termines quoi je suis en
terminale pro bon très bien tu veux
faire quoi dans la vie du commerce du
commerce
de mettre des musiques
mais tu es con un petit commis alors en
deux points j'ai l'impression que tu
joues bien je vois comment tu t'attends
[Applaudissements]
on peut dire à la vieille de leur mode
d'arrêter de faire du bruit s'il vous
plaît merci
mon chéri
[Applaudissements]
comment tu t'appelles ma chérie
Alexandra
[Rires]
éducation j'adore santé éducation
santé éducation
de l'éducation de l'éducation ah ouais
tu peux pas t'occuper de mon fils
[Rires]
en quelle année première année la
première année
toi les bonnes questions ma chérie tu
joues bien votre père
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal le gars n'aura pas les 100 balles
mais c'est pas mal merci
ma chérie
si vous savez pas jouer ne venez pas
comment ça va toi tu ressors d'un
concert de rock toi
j'adore ça va mon chéri
[Rires]
tu fais quoi dans la vie
d'accord tu as la voix de Zidane sur la
tête
j'ai mis la chaussette la chaussette
droite puis la chaussette gauche et puis
j'ai plus de la
volvices où à Toulouse
quelle belle ville ah j'adore la ville
la ville rose
c'est Toulouse
ma carrière tu le saurais avec Bigflo et
les connard ça va mon chéri j'adore bon
tu es prêt tu es marié et fiancé
toute la famille
vous êtes son prénom non mais non mais
demande-lui
à Stéphane pardon c'est bien tu suis
vas-y c'est faux
j'avais une branche dans la main en mode
à mon avis je ne tape de ping-pong à la
maison
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui fait ça à 8h par jour on a pas le
ralenti supplément au début je veux me
revoir
mettez-moi le ralenti de la balle au
début c'est pas plus compliqué
au début j'avais dit c'est monstrueux en
tout cas c'est très très beau comment tu
t'intitule Alexandre ça va elle sois pas
énervée ça va ça va
je suis au lycée
j'ai besoin qu'il y a que des
trafiquants
à chaque fois que je lui demande ce
qu'il fait dans la vie quoi
18 18 ans je t'explique j'étais déjà en
3e année d'acheter
on faisait un double cursus
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je veux comment tu tiens ta raquette tu
sais déjà que tu es une chèvre
allez vas-y mon chien
est pas mal
tu as pas un beau style mais c'est
efficace la grande table il serait
meilleur
merci mon chéri merci mon chéri d'amour
merci mon chéri merci merci
[Applaudissements]
tu fais quoi là tu as pas école là
tu fais quoi dans la vie 11 secondes pas
mal à 16 ans normalement c'est bien tu
as une meuf toi aussi euh non non ça
sert à rien
je vois que tu vois tu connais la vie de
Benjamin Castaldi
il est incroyable bon mon chéri tu sais
quoi tu t'appelles tu m'appelles
Pierre-Louis Pierre-Louis d'accord comme
les femmes
allez c'est parti mon chat essaie de
gagner les 100 balles ça me ferait
plaisir parce que je t'aime beaucoup
j'ai bien
la balle elle est partie là elle est
partie elle est partie sur France 5
il faut pas de ma gueule là
le Vienne que les gens qui savent jouer
viens ma chérie
tu fais quoi dans la vie je suis en bac
en terminale accompagnement
je suis là en ami ça va tu es un mec non
tu as rien tu es célibataire tranquille
tu joues ping-pong un peu oui tu te fous
de ma gueule
tu sens que tu vas me défoncer en plus
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est pas sérieux je suis désolé les
gars elle est trop petit
je m'appelle Cassandra tu es magnifique
c'est quoi ces ongles c'était vrai c'est
vrai ou tu as mis un téléphone
je te jure que c'est vrai mais des pieds
[Rires]
tu prends soin de toi ça me fait plaisir
tu joues ping-pong ou tu viens juste
pour montrer ta ganache
c'est bon donne-moi cette balle non mais
les mecs
là
c'est Hanouna là j'ai battu Djokovic
j'ai battu les Wawrinka j'ai battu
Gasquet j'ai battu tous les plus grands
joueurs non le crétin il est là
et je vous dis donc là les gars vous
venez là la gueule en biais la gueule en
farine et vous croyez que vous allez
gagner les 100 balles les mecs ne
viennent que ceux qui savent nourrit qui
sait jouer qui sait jouer là-bas arrêtez
tout [__] de ma gueule [__] arrêtez
comme par hasard on a un public c'est
que des champions de ping-pong
arrêtez les gars pas à moi
belle leçon de vie Cyril quand on bosse
on réussit beaucoup d'entraînement et
mais
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça que j'aurais avec
nous Paris Paris
[Musique]
je
mets Dieu la la la la la la
sur les quais de
vos gueules
elle va être intimidée
c'est parti deux points pour 100 balles
c'est pas mal
[Rires]
c'est parti on y va allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
merci et un partout ce n'est rien je
n'ai fait que mon métier
je peux te faire un bisou
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais toi
pour une comédie musicale
ton entrée refait ton entrée et
incroyable elle fait avancer sur ma
vidéo
les rois du monde vivre sans mal ils ont
la plus belle vue mais il y a un mâle ça
va ma chérie merci comment tu t'appelles
Myriam Myriam
ça me permet de voir vraiment vous
faites des efforts plus que les
chroniqueurs pour venir
regarder l'autre on dirait qu'elle
travaille dans une droguerie
je suis ravi de ma mère tu as envie de
demander un balai pour les chiottes et
sans déconner et du CIF ammoniacal c'est
horrible sans déconner
en écu euh
on a l'impression qu'elle est dans la
petite maison dans la prairie oui madame
c'est un financier mais pas le le gâteau
alors ma chérie on va jouer au ping-pong
tu joues pour 100 balles tu joues bien
alors je fais du scotch d'accord mais
c'est tout
de direction
[Rires]
allez c'est parti
il y a du
c'est un attentat et le square et le
squash
merci merci ma chérie
la dernière
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ce prénom j'adore tu fais quoi
dans la vie je suis en terminale bac pro
commerce
tous ceux qui me regardent ce soir a été
personnel
[Rires]
tu as raison mais aussi j'adorais tout
seul dans cette émission
même plus 4 5 6 6 rends toi tu es très
sympathique j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup
[Musique]
merci merci ma chérie d'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu donnes pas tu donnes rien donné dans
ta vie tu me donnes rien non mais je te
dis rien
tu t'en vas tu fous rien toi aussi
[Applaudissements]